[Music]
[Applause]
this morning on the dish a chef
breaking stereotypes in food and life
chef akhtar nawab is a first
generation indian american with
classical training in italian
and french earning accolades for his
mexican cuisine
he worked in some of new york's best
known restaurants like the iconic
gramercy tavern
before venturing out on his own and now
after 25 years in the restaurant
industry
he's published his first cookbook good
for you bold flavors with benefits
believing food that is good for you
should taste good too
for chef akhtar nawab there's joy in
igniting
the flavor and taste of foods both
familiar
and new it's like playful and
experimenting and i think getting in
touch with
a new set of ingredients and new flavors
i think is actually very exciting
and the diversity of the dishes he
creates
be it here in brooklyn for his mexican
restaurant alta calidad
shakshuka which is a really traditional
middle eastern dish it's been repurposed
a little with these mexican
flavors so it has poblano peppers and
some cumin and
coriander eggplant red onions and this
is more of our alta kali dad type
spreads
crispy shrimp with salsa seca more
traditional charred steak tacos and then
a little
indian inspired charred pea shoots with
crispy chunno
this is archuros our version of churros
so it's like a request on which is like
a ricotta cheese
gently folded and then we cook it gently
until they're crisp and airy
or for his newly released cookbook so
it's a gluten-free and dairy-free rice
pudding
enriched with a little cashew puree are
matched
by the diversity of the chef himself i'm
an indian
born in milwaukee raised racing kentucky
cooking mexican
noah's parents and older brother moved
from india to milwaukee in 1969 when his
father a cardiovascular surgeon
was offered a job five years later the
family
then including nawab made louisville
kentucky
home you know louisville is a great
place to grow up it was easy to run into
people at the grocery stores a very
small
community but i always felt as though we
were
one of very few indian families as nwab
describes in that new cookbook
he grew up a first generation son of
indian parents in a town
marked by white bread who spent weekends
in the kitchen cooking sag paneer and
kemah with his mom i never lost sight of
the fact that i always had
really good close friends but i always
understood that we were
a little different than than some of the
other families do you think that's
shaped you now
definitely i think it's well i think
it's definitely made me
more welcoming of you know like learning
mexican food after having cooked french
and italian
and just mediterranean and refined
american embraced
the diversity in a different way i guess
totally it's not only in his
food that nawab embraces that diversity
it's also within the very foundation of
his business
because i'm looking at the wall by the
way no walls here
we support the dreamers we've had that
up for almost four years
before this became a fight that people
were more pronounced in
yes where does that come from
[Music]
we employ a lot of immigrants
and
it's important to protect them
this means a lot to you why does it mean
that much to you
you know a lot of these people have very
little
to give them an opportunity is important
to treat them well is important so
i mean they just depend on us when nawab
started in the restaurant business as a
20 year old
he was the one counting on help from
others
he spent a decade working his way from
the california culinary academy
to legendary kitchens on both coasts
working under tom colicchio at gramercy
tavern in new york
only after nawab says loretta keller
laid the foundation in san francisco
what did you learn from loretta that's
where you learn how to extract all these
flavors of ingredients and understand
what good ingredients
are and not to fuss with things too much
the skill is in preparing what you have
not necessarily twisting
and manipulating what you're given then
tom really had that same
approach an approach nawab used at age
32
when he opened his first restaurant
aylataria
serving those indian flavors of
childhood it would last
just one year the food was good
everything else didn't work
i just didn't have the experience at the
time to manage people
to be responsible for the cost component
years later i look back on it and i say
it was really important that it didn't
work out turns out
nawab's failure led to his success
out of work feeling lost and uncertain
he spent time with his then toddler
daughter
ella and that role as single dad taught
both
father and chef an important lesson
it really taught me patience and more
than anything
it's like understanding that not
everything is going to
materialize today tomorrow but you know
it's a process
which for nawab included a headhunter
suggesting a shift
to mexican cuisine i said i don't really
know anything about it
as i got deeper involved and i saw
similarities between the indian food i
grew up with
and all of all of these other flavors
and characteristics that were so similar
i felt much more comfortable quickly a
lot of the people who
live around us are our customers as he
embraced mexican cooking
nawab was also able to embrace new
possibilities
in 2016 he and his business partner
opened
altacalidad followed by otravase in new
orleans and prather's alley in dc
taquerias and a food hall are now also a
part of their ever growing
and diversifying portfolio when someone
eats
a meal when i sure take bites of this
what do you hope
that i take with me or get from it i
would love for people to say this isn't
exactly what i thought this is better
i'm experiencing flavors i wouldn't
anticipate
it's beautiful and fresh it feels good
i feel healthy i mean all of those
things
and i tasted a lot that day the the rice
pudding that i tasted
i ate the entire thing it was delicious
what we have here for you though a
little bit of the alta cali
tacos and then our drink is coyote
wishes and aperol spritz but again that
idea of the diversity it's
an apparel spirit that's made with
mezcal
awesome coyote wishes coyote what a cool
name
cheers to you all cheers that was such a
poignant moment it really was
um with you and and him talking about
his employees
well and remember he's first generation
so his family he's from a family of
immigrants
and and this is important to him to
continue
giving them opportunities the way his
family had opportunities as well
and delicious food and he didn't forget
it that's the important thing
no he didn't so i'm gonna take a bite of
my vegetarian taco
toss it i mean i'll do it this is the
part of the show where we have to
pound a drink eat and then speak to the
prompter